my name is Emma Stone I am playing Bella
Baxter in the film poor things this is
Bella she's an experiments she is
understanding what it is to be a member
of society good evening the more
autonomous she becomes the more
challenged men seem to be by it Bella
Bella sexuality it's an incredibly
important part of the story The Human
Experience is fascinating to her sex is
a major part of that why do people not
do this all the time m
I wanted to play Bella because it felt
like acceptance of what it is to be a
woman to be free to be scared and brave
we must experience everything Bella this
makes us
home Yus has giv me a gift by asking me
to be a producer on this I've gotten to
be very privy to the whole process that
I wouldn't have if I were just acting in
it it just felt like the perfect
combination better why I keep it in my
mouth if it is
revolting